[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
hello and good evening table people
non-table people whoever may be out
there tonight
we welcome you to this space you are so
welcome and so wanted and it's an
honor to share it with you i don't know
what your neck of the woods is like
right now wherever you're at but
it's like drizzly and cold here so i'm
prepared i have like
hot tea in hand i have my puppy dog
sitting at my feet
warming me and i'm just
very honored to be here with you and um
looking forward to what god has in store
tonight and
definitely entering in with an expectant
heart um
i do want to share one quick
announcement about
this coming sunday it is november the
1st
and you guys that marks our one
year anniversary at the table which is
crazy to think
that a year ago november was our fir
first week of november was our first
live service at the table
and um so much has happened who could
have known
what 2020 would hold in store we had no
idea when we started this church at that
timing
um what a crazy window of history this
was going to be
and i can't tell you what a blessing it
is to think that we're
here and that we were able to do that
before the pandemic kit and and
just create the relationships that we
have so far it's such an honor
we want to celebrate that moment with
you and we want to do it
in person in some way shape or form even
though
we're trying to be as quarantine
friendly as possible
we would love to see your faces and if
you
are open to it we would love to invite
you to join us next
sunday november 1st at pleasant valley
united methodist church in
saxi um it will be from 4 to 6 p.m
and we are going to have a communion
service
and we have a gift that we'd like to
give you just for us to tangibly show
our
thanks that you are part of this
community to tell you how
much it has meant to us and honestly to
give thanks to god and to just thank him
for the work that he is
doing among us has been and continues to
do
um we would love to see you there to
pray for you to share communion with you
and to share this gift
so next sunday november 1st 4-6 p.m
pleasant valley united methodist church
in saxi
please come we would love to see you
um that being said we're going to go
ahead and start transitioning into our
service
and i want to just read something so let
me just
set down this t and um i've been working
my way through a book by richard rohr
called falling upward and um
i don't know how this series has been
hitting you guys over the last few weeks
as we've been dealing with
some of the difficult scriptures um
and the parts of the bible that have
honestly just pushed
so many people away from the church away
from god away from scripture altogether
and um that can be difficult territory
but at the same time if we do not step
into that territory
my fear is that um
we lose a lot more than just our
relationship with scripture
we uh so many of us so many people have
ended up losing their relationship or
their connection
to christ and especially to the body of
christ
so i wanted to just read something that
felt like it resonated with the
territory that we're in right now
as we kick off the service tonight and
um i just hope it kind of prepares the
table the table
so to speak for what um josh will be
sharing with us in worship what brett
will be sharing with us
um for the uh sermon tonight and
um yeah if you'll just listen to this
it says jesus had
no trouble with the exceptions whether
they were
prostitutes drunkards samaritans
lepers gentiles tax collectors or
wayward sheep he ate with outsiders
regularly
to the chagrin of the church stalwarts
who always
love their version of order over any
compassion towards the exceptions
this ability to adjust to human disorder
and failure is named god's providence or
compassion
every time god forgives us god is saying
that god's own rules do not matter as
much
as the relationships that god wants to
create
with us so
as we enter in i hope we can keep
that center focus on connection and
relationship to him tonight
let me say a prayer just to transition
us to josh as he leads us in
some worship music
father i thank you that you
are so expansive
you continue to expand our ideas
of who is welcome
our ideas of how far your grace
extends
our ideas of what it looks like to
belong to you
god i ask that you would surprise us
with your presence
again tonight here in this service god
we open our hearts
and our minds to you
god i ask that each person here with us
would truly receive from you tonight
and from the love of this community i
thank you for it
in jesus name i pray amen
thank you
hey everybody uh thank you maggie i hope
everybody's having a great week this
week
before we start singing i just wanted to
because i was thinking about it and i
really miss
the human connection uh and i know i'm
really thankful that we're
being responsible in how we're how we're
dealing with all this but
i do miss the human connection so before
we start singing i wanted to try and
create a human connection um
just to get our minds and our bodies our
souls all in line
um to hear what brett has to say uh or
or to what god has to say to us while we
sing so
if if you have a moment if you're
sitting down uh just sit back and close
your eyes
as the as the music plays sing along if
you know the words
uh and just imagine yourself floating on
your back
in the middle of the ocean you can't see
land anywhere
and imagine that that water you're
floating in is just the
like maggie said the expansive love of
god
uh and some of the words that we're
gonna sing tonight i mean the the very
first one
uh the first line is he is jealous for
me
whoa i mean you know i hear that line
and i think of all the mistakes
uh all the shame that i've felt in my
life and uh
there's this great loving
being this great loving energy that
doesn't care that he's still jealous for
me and he wants me
so just sit back and uh
yeah leave behind all of uh your regrets
your mistakes
um maybe your bad week even your good
week just just
relax in the love of god
[Music]
he is jealous for me
love like a hurricane i
am a tree bending beneath
the weight of his wind and mercy
[Music]
glory and i realize
just how beautiful you are
i pray your affections are for me
to how he loves
us
[Music]
how he loves us
so
and oh how he
loves us so
oh how he loves
us how he
loves us
[Music]
he is jealous for me
like a hurricane i am a tree
bending beneath the weight of his
rental mercy
[Music]
just
how he loves us so
how he loves us
are you hurting broken
thin overwhelmed by the weight of your
sin
jesus is calling
[Music]
have you come to the air of yourself
do your thirst for a dream from the well
jesus is calling
o come to the altar
the father's arms are
open wide forgiveness
was bought with the precious blood of
jesus christ
[Music]
leave behind your regrets and mistake
come today there's no reason to wait
jesus is calling
[Music]
bring your sorrow and trade them for joy
from the ashes a new life is born
jesus is calling
[Music]
oh come to the altar
the father's arms are
open wide forgiveness
was bought with the precious blood
of jesus christ so
come to the altar
the father's arms are
open wide for kindness
was bought with the precious
blood of jesus christ
i don't want to save
[Music]
hallelujah
christ is rising
[Music]
for he is lord of hearts
hallelujah
christ is a reason
[Music]
yeah he loves us
oh how he loves
[Music]
us
oh
[Music]
drawn to redemption by the grace in his
eyes
if grace is an ocean
we're all sinking
so heaven meets earth like a sloppy wet
kiss
and my heart turns violently inside of
my chest
i don't have time to maintain these
regrets when i think
[Music]
[Applause]
oh how he loves
[Music]
us
doesn't he want her for
[Music]
sing hallelujah
christ is reason
bow down before him
for he is lord of hearts
sing hallelujah
christ is a reason
[Music]
i don't want to say
isn't he wonderful
sing hallelujah
christ is rising
[Music]
feel your cross as you wait for the
crown
tell the world of the treasure
you found
[Music]
oh great loving god thank you for
covering us in your love
for seeing past our humanness
and being jealous for us or may your
love
swallow us up tonight as we hear
from brett thank you guys
thank you josh well good evening
everyone
grace and peace welcome to the table
and uh before we jump in i did want to
just encourage you all
uh to just like maggie was talking about
just to join us next week
for our drive through communion service
so we will not be here
nothing online um and basically
um maggie brittany miranda there's been
a number of people who have kind of all
working together to like pull
pull this off and it's gonna be a really
special time like this is not going to
be just pull through we're like hi there
here's communion bye i mean it's we're
going to like take some time to say hi
we're going to like pray for you take
communion um we also have a gift like
there's
a few things going on like we're really
trying to make it something special
um so i just i encourage you like you
don't want to miss out you don't i just
know
some of you are going to think like oh
no this is no big deal and then you're
going to be like wait what
and yeah don't fomo right don't don't
yeah
all right so sign up i posted the link
earlier i think maybe marissa
uh we'll post it again and um so anyway
yeah go ahead oh anna thanks to marissa
she's kind of behind the scenes tonight
in our hostess role
um helping out and posting things so
thank you marissa um all right
so we are in y'all this is part five of
our series
titled scripture dealing with difficult
texts
and uh in this series we're really not
only looking at
you know just specific bible verses that
down through christian history have been
seen as kind of problematic
um but really we're asking even a much
bigger question like
how do we approach the bible as a whole
how do we think of
scripture as a whole like what what is
scripture so if you missed um
previous weeks i really encourage you to
go back and catch up
um via the podcast and if you don't have
time to listen to them all
at least engage week one of this series
it was titled an ancient
approach to the bible since in so many
ways that message
really kind of laid the groundwork for
the entire
series so tonight the title of my
message is the good news about the bad
place
and i mean goodness if there is like
probably any topic that has
um like maggie mentioned kind of pushed
people away from
church and things um it's been hell
so uh that's that's kind of our topic
for tonight so before we jump in though
i do have a few quick
footnotes um so first
i said this in week one but i'll say it
again um kind of what i'm giving you
today
is really it's it's some theology that
i've worked through this is how i've
made sense of things
so i do not speak on behalf of everyone
at our church
it's perfectly okay if you want to
disagree with me
um that's that's fine like we can both
be in community
and and disagree um on this topic so
that's the first footnote second
footnote
is i want to go ahead and give you a few
resources that i've found really helpful
um kind of not only in preparing this
specific message but really
kind of thinking through this topic over
the last
many many years probably 10 years or so
uh so the first
two are easier reads the last two are a
little more scholarly in nature
um so c.s lewis the great divorce
it sounds like it's a book on marriage
or something it is not at all um it is
about heaven and hell
uh that's the great divorce the divide
um it's a brilliant book
brilliant brilliant brilliant it's kind
of a parable in a story
and um he was probably the first person
that got me thinking about
um hell in like different ways um so
that's for cs lewis and rob bell
is the second one uh love wins his uh
famous or infamous book depending on
your perspective
that he came out with a few years ago um
both lewis and
and bell are kind of coming from uh like
they're really speaking to evangelicals
and like protestant
folks um so if you're kind of coming
from that background those first two
might be helpful
um this third one hans urzvan balthazar
dear we hope that all men be saved
you wrote this book quite a while ago so
he means all humankind
not literally males um and so he
balthazar is coming from a catholic
perspective so that's your background
um this book might be really helpful
and then finally david bentley heart
that all shall be saved
and heart is coming from an eastern
orthodox um kind of perspective and a
very kind of philosophical um systematic
kind of way so
um like i mentioned those last two are a
little more scholarly scholarly
in nature um all right so enough
footnoting
let's jump in for tonight so kind of the
way i want to frame this is with
um kind of the challenge here's the
theological challenge the conundrum the
problem
uh that we need to solve tonight so
effectively the new testament clearly
teaches both
the reality of a post-mortem you know an
after death
kind of judgment um you know in other
words like
hell as well as the fact
that all will be saved um what i'm
calling universalism
so in other words you have bible verses
that point clearly in both these
directions
uh now to clarify a lot of folks you
know are unfamiliar like you know
universalism uh so universalism is the
belief that
all people will be saved um of course
you know there's like different kind of
versions of it and such but we're not
gonna we're not gonna get into all that
this is just kind of a
down and dirty like simple um definition
is the belief that all people will be
saved
and so um while universalism has
not been the dominant view kind of like
the majority of you throughout christian
history
it has been a very strong minority view
uh in other words you have kind of all
throughout church history
folks who did hold to to this idea that
all will be saved
um and uh and in fact you could even
argue
that it was the majority position
for the first um maybe you know
two three four hundred years of
christian history
uh there's a few quotes from the church
fathers that that seem to kind of
indicate this
um so that's i think that's really worth
naming like
you know we have reasonably that the
teaching that all will be saved was the
dominant view in the early church
uh which for most of us right that makes
like no sense
because we're like wait what but
the hell damnation judgment pitchforks
dancing devils right fire forever like
if if there's a hell well how can all
humanity be
saved right these two ideas like this
doesn't make sense
um and of course that's the key question
right that's that's why this needs
answering
uh so first i want to kind of look at
some relevant biblical text we will be
all in the bible tonight so if you have
your bible
you'll want to get it ready um and i
want to start with passages
relating to hell now
you'll notice um that a lot of the kind
of mythology we've built up around the
idea of hell
is quite absent from these texts you
know our our image of hell is kind of
this place where like the devil
he's in control and the demons are
torturing people
um and that's you know that's not quite
it's probably a little more dante's
inferno kind of medieval
christianity than um bible um
now having said that uh it's
i mean it's it's true that you know the
way the bible describes hell it does not
it does not sound like good times right
so i'm not trying to say like oh no
biggs
um so let's look at a few of these
matthew chapter 10 verse 28
this is jesus speaking he says do not be
afraid of those who kill the body
but cannot kill the soul rather be
afraid of
the one um maybe
the devil we're not totally sure the one
um who can destroy
both soul and body in hell
and then matthew 13 verses 43 43 again
jesus
as the weeds are pulled up and burned in
the fire
so it will be at the end of the age the
son of man will send out his angels
and they will weed out of his kingdom
everything that causes
sin and all who do evil verse 42 they
will
throw them into the blazing furnace
where there will be weeping
and gnashing of teeth then the righteous
will shine like the sun
in the kingdom of their father whoever
has ears
let them hear and then finally mark
9 verses 43-48 jesus says if your hand
causes you to stumble
cut it off it is better for you to enter
life
maimed than with two hands to go into
hell
where the fire never goes out um i do
want a name jesus
is using he's using hyperbole here right
so there's nothing in christian
tradition that says like actually do
this
okay so he's he's using hyperbole to
make a point
um all right fire never goes out verse
45 and if your foot causes you to
stumble
again hyperbolically cut it off it's
better for you to enter life crippled
than to have two feet and be thrown into
hell
and if your eye causes you to stumble
pluck it out
it's better for you to enter the kingdom
of god with one eye than to have
two eyes and be thrown into hell
where the worms that eat them do not die
and the fire
is not quenched that last line about the
worms that's from
isaiah chapter 66 uh we're actually kind
of describing a battle
there um but it looks like maybe jesus
is kind of interpreting that spiritually
or something
so so uh the thing i want to name here
um notice you know these are the words
of
jesus himself right so this is not about
saying like oh that's old testament
teaching
so we don't really need to talk about
hell no no these these are all quotes
from jesus
and in fact strangely enough the old
testament doesn't
doesn't actually talk about hell at all
instead it talks about a place called
sheol which is simply just the place of
the dead
uh but it the the old testament really
doesn't have any clear teaching on the
afterlife it's kind of
you know hazy just some i guess people
go somewhere
um but it's not distinguishing between
like the righteous and the unrighteous
or the good the bad or something
uh and honestly it's kind of similar for
the apostle paul um
we'll see later he kind of hints at
something like like this
like hell but in terms of there's no
passages in paul
in the later new testament that describe
hell in quite the same way that that
jesus
does in those passages um
so i mean having said that though jesus
is talking about it
and so i don't think um christians
you know can just say like oh i just you
know i just believe god's love and so i
i just dismiss hell or i just don't
believe in it or something um
you know jesus talks about it so it's
something we need to really wrestle with
um now as i named earlier though we also
need to reckon
uh with the more what i'm calling
universalist
passages these are the the verses that
indicate um that
all people will be saved
uh here's the big list uh scott's on
tech
so he can go ahead and put this list up
i don't think i need to read
all of these um but let me just i'll
start and if i get tired i'll just stop
um so romans 5 18-19 first corinthians
15 22
2nd corinthians 5 14 romans 11 32 first
timothy 2 3 through 6 titus 211
2nd corinthians 5 19 ephesians 1 9
through 10 colossians 1 27-28 john 12 32
hebrews 2 9 john 4 42 john 12 47 first
john four
okay now i'm gonna start doing just
chapters second peter three and there's
one in matthew 18 and philippians 2 and
colossians 1
and 1st john 2 and john 3
and luke 16 and 1st timothy 4 10. all
right
so i name all those because i just i i
i wanted to name that i'm not simply um
you know finding like one passage
in the bible and then you know building
an entire doctrine around
around that that's not um that's not a
wise thing to do so
um as you can see there there's a lot
like many many passages
that kind of point in this direction of
all people being saved
so let's go ahead and i do want to read
a few of these
um i have mercy on you we will not go
through all of those in detail
but i do want to touch on a few so let's
start with some from jesus himself
and then we'll shift to the apostle paul
so john 12 32
jesus says and i when i am lifted up
from the earth
will draw all people
to myself then john 12 47
jesus again if anyone hears my words but
does not keep them i do not judge that
person
for i did not come to judge the world
but
to what to save the world
here's a few from the apostle paul
romans 5 18-19
consequently just as one
trespass in other words one kind of like
misstep one sin resulted in condemnation
for all people so he's thinking here of
course the story of adam and eve so it's
the misstep of adam
so also one righteous act resulted in
justification and life for all people
that would be jesus the cross
resurrection right so he's kind of
doing this this um this comparison
uh and then verse 19 he kind of
emphasized it again for just as through
the disobedience of
the one man the many were made sinners
so
also through the obedience of the one
man
the many will be made righteous that
word righteous just means right with god
right with others right with ourselves
um first corinthians 15
22 for as in adam
all die so in christ
what all will be made alive
uh now you know biblical commentators
and folks who are trying to kind of make
sense of this
in light of the the idea of hell will
often say like well hmm
okay well maybe what this means is that
you know while
yes all humanity is subject to you know
sin and death because of
um you know adam's misstep so well
so in christ all but it doesn't mean all
it means you know all the believers all
the believers
will be made alive because you know the
meaning of any text it's kind of
dependent on its context
uh but actually you know for most of
these and i gave you that big list
earlier if you actually look at the
context
um i you know it it's
it it doesn't seem like it's saying that
um you know well all means all the
believers
uh instead all seems to mean
all all creation all humanity
uh here's another one this is first
timothy two three through
six this is good and pleases god our
savior
who wants all people to
be saved and to come to a knowledge of
the truth
for there is one god and one mediator
between god and mankind the man
christ jesus who gave himself as a
ransom
for who all people
finally colossians 1 19-20 for god was
pleased paul writes
to have all his fullness dwell in
him and through him that's jesus to
reconcile to himself what
all things whether things on earth or
things in heaven
by making peace through his bloodshed
on the cross in other words who did
jesus die for
everyone and who does he reconcile who
does he
make right according to colossians he
well he
he makes right at every one right who
who does
who does he bring into right
relationship who does his boundless love
reach uh the good people
the christian-y people well
i mean yes them but not only them right
on the cross
jesus embraces everyone
as the text says all things
that's pretty that's pretty expansive
right it's not even like
all people it's like literally
all things this is why you'll often hear
me in my preaching i'll describe
humanity i'll say something like um the
god from whom we
all came and to whom we will all return
right that's a very biblical idea we all
came from god we
all will return to god um at the end of
all
things right that's i'm getting that
language from places like colossians
this this all things it means literally
the entire created
order um and he says i think because
it's not hard to look around right and
say
something's wrong with this world
something's not right with it
it's it's a world at war with itself
and so paul is saying this is how
powerful
the love of christ on the cross is
he he stretches his arms wide and he
reaches he embraces he touches who
everyone no matter who they are or what
they've done no matter how
worthy or unworthy regardless of their
religious or moral standing
the cross the resurrection it cuts
through it
all and it makes a way
hey man man i wish i was in person that
would be worth the
like something like right this is and
this is why by the way
come on people like this is why it's
called the good news
right and not the mixed news like
i mean if if the gospel is something
like this
um you know through the cross of jesus a
small minority of human beings who have
ever lived will be united with god
while the vast majority of people who do
not believe or perhaps never even heard
will be tortured for all eternity by a
loving god
like can you hear the dissonance there
like i
okay i mean i guess it's good news that
like at least some will
you know but i yeah there's some there's
something off there
um which honestly brings us right back
to our original problem
right in the new testament we have both
a a postmortem and an after death
judgment by fire being described by
jesus
himself coupled with even jesus himself
indicating all will be saved so
so what on earth are we to think and and
i think the key question for us is how
did early christians
interpret these texts um
well let me start with what they did not
do they did not dismiss
the idea of hell um and and honestly
most
um did not dismiss the idea that all
would be saved
instead what they did is they came back
to some of their first principles let me
go ahead and give you some of
of these these are like key things
that they really drew on so principle
number one god they said
is infinite love and
goodness right if you've been around for
this series
you hopefully this idea is like getting
through um
it's because i keep saying it over and
over it's not simply
that god chooses to love or like that he
has some love
or even that love is one attribute among
others in him no that's not how the
bible describes it
no god is
love and you might ask well how do you
know because
as we talked about last week god looks
like jesus hanging on a cross
and as he hangs there what does he say
not roast them in hell forever lord
vindicate your servant
no what does he say father forgive
them they do not know what they
are doing that's what love looks like
god looks like jesus
hanging on the cross god looks like
jesus
being raised from the dead seeing the
disciples for the first time
the disciples by the way who mostly
betrayed and abandoned him those those
disciples
and he sees them and what does he say
peace
peace be with you right the the image of
god we see in jesus is not bitter or
angry
coercive or violent no god is
pure love infinite goodness
in fact writing um many many years later
one of those very disciples who
experienced the cross who experienced
the resurrection
and and then he lived with jesus for
three years he wrote these words this is
first john 4 starting in verse 7
beloved he writes many years later let
us love one another
for love is from god and whoever loves
has been
born of god and knows god anyone who
does not love
does not know god because god
is love verse 18 there is no fear
in love but perfect love casts out
fear for fear has to do with punishment
whoever fears has not been perfected
in love oh we love because he first
loved us right god is
infinite love and goodness itself which
means
anything that emanates from him
in any decision any action
must be rooted in the soil
of love it's like honestly i think a
great
example it's like being a parent you
know one of the things i don't like in
myself
um because i am not infinite love and
goodness i know one things i hate
is when i discipline one of my kids from
that
um anger might be putting it mildly
borderline rage just like oh my gosh
where i just get
i just get so pissed right and and i
it's the weirdest thing i swear i can be
like an angel
70 of the day okay
maybe 30 percent of the day and then
it's 9 p.m
and my kids aren't staying in their
freaking beds
and i'm about to lose my mind and what
happens
they feel the wrath of the father okay
i'm not like abusive um but
right but at my best when i punish my
kids at my best right that's at my worst
but at my best
it's not a repay evil for evil
um at my best i'm not indulgent with
them right i'm just like oh what ifs
no but i i still can punish but but i'm
doing it from this very
calm loving heart where where i can say
okay okay look here's here's
the results here's the consequences
here's the punishment it's and this
is not to get back at you but it's to
teach
and i think so it is with the god who is
love
right even his judgment is
motivated by love
now uh you might i can imagine someone
saying like okay
yeah i get it i get it um but let's just
run with this metaphor bret of a good
parent who
you know never punishes and like rage or
wrath but but always punishes from love
okay so if if god is that parent um
then i'm afraid that god roasting his
kids as you said the metaphor um in
fire for all eternity is uh
i'm just gonna you know out on the limb
and say that's not appropriate
punishment
like i don't care how much love you say
god has in his heart as he does it
uh that's just like sick
um okay a fair critique and
this uh leads us to principle number two
uh that many many early christians
adhere to principle number two
they interpreted that the fires of hell
are spiritual and metaphorical the idea
was basically
that the god of infinite love and
goodness
would not create and sustain a place
of of literal infinite torment
and torture so instead they said
okay no the fire it's it's a metaphor
and it's a metaphor of purification
right so it is a spiritual fire and as
you know
um i mean what does fire do fire fire
cleanses
and fire purifies this is why
you for example um can put you know raw
gold and what do they do when they have
gold and they need to purify they put it
into
fire because the the dross
that which is not gold um it burns off
or it rises to the surface and can be
discarded
right well and what remains the pure
gold remains
so early christians said uh we we
know the character of jesus
we know the father um okay so
so that's that's what must be going
on and a very essential passage in this
regard
um was first corinthians chapter 3
verses 10 through 15
and honestly this is a beautiful passage
and you'll start to see
how this understanding of hell and
judgment
kind of flows into the concept of
universal
salvation how they're actually connected
so this is the apostle paul writing to
a local church he says in verse 10
by the grace god has given me i laid a
foundation
as a wise builder and someone else is
building on it but
but each one should build with care
uh quick side note he's not talking
about like building houses here he's
talking about
um how you and i build our lives that
first kind of
he helped them build theirs and now
they're gonna have to do their own
building so verse 11
for no one can lay any foundation
other than the one already laid which is
jesus christ another side note so you
can see
um that that the cross and resurrection
of jesus
are essential for paul right everything
is grace for us
christ is our foundation um but the
question
is what kind of life what kind of
response
um will we have what what kind of of
life will we build
on that foundation verse 12 if anyone
builds
on this foundation using gold
silver costly stones
or wood hay or straw their work
will be shown for what it is
because the day notice it's a capital d
day this is the day of judgment that the
day that each of us stands before god
the day will bring it to light
it will be revealed with what
with fire and the fire
will test the quality of each
person's work verse 14 if what has been
built
survives the builder will receive a
reward
if it is burned up the builder
will suffer loss let's go ahead and
pause
there so paul is saying
that each of us will build
a life on christ and it will either be a
life
of unsurpassing beauty a
life built on love on goodness
a a life clothed in humility a life of
peacemaking a life where we
bring heaven to earth or
it will be a life of what he calls wood
hay
and straw a life
where where we basically brought hell to
earth to the people around us where we
lived in resentment with bitterness
perhaps even
violence there was there was injustice
that there was
hatred in our hearts
and even if we said like you know jesus
or god or lord lord or i'm a
church-going person
but if right because we're building on a
foundation
but if we did that but we were the whole
time lost in our own ego
in selfish desires and we we just missed
it
right we missed the glory this is where
jesus says like not everyone who says in
that day oh lord lord you're
you're the greatest you're awesome i
praise you like he's like
i don't there's a disconnect here
and um and of course i think you know on
earth
it's it's not always clear um what kind
of life
we are building um you know perhaps it's
a beautiful life of gold and silver
perhaps it's just a bunch of
straw or maybe you're like me it's just
a bit of a mixed bag
so what is this saying what is this text
saying it's saying god is the judge
a loving judge like a good and wise
parent
but a judge nonetheless and on that day
our lives will be judged there's a
strange paradox in the new testament
that we're
we're saved by the graced goodness of
god
but we're judged by our works
interesting paradox but you see it all
through
i mean it's unmistakable and so he's
saying on that day our lives will be
judged and paul
gives i think i think it's a powerful
image
of someone did you kind of catch it it's
almost as though someone's like passing
through a fire right he says
the fire will test the quality of a
person's
work and and you ask okay so
is that like when we're all tortured for
many sins
uh i don't think so because again what
what is a fire a metaphor of
it's it's a purifying fire
right this is why it doesn't contradict
principle number one
the fire is god's grace and goodness
to us he is setting
us free and as we pass through that
spiritual fire
whatever crap has haunted us
whatever addictions have dragged us down
whatever hatred or bitterness
unforgiveness depression rage
all the wood hay and straw of our lives
all the stupid decisions
and regrets what's happening it's just
it's
burning away it's burning away
the fires of god's furious love
are setting you free
and perhaps you say well alright here's
the problem
i'm a i'm a bad person and i've done
unspeakable things i mean what if what
if my life's
all wood hay and straw i mean maybe some
of us
just really are too far gone
let's finish the passage beginning in
verse 13. paul says the fire it will
test
the quality of each person's work and if
what has been built survives right so if
something
survives the builder will receive a
reward but
if it is burned up so the image there is
like it's a goner
right if it is burned up the builder
will suffer loss
but yet will be
saved even though only as one
escaping through the flames
so did you catch it he did he didn't say
so some folks are just all wood hay and
straw and so they're annihilated or they
burn in hell forever
no paul says even they will be saved
though it will be a bit of a close call
and this is how um this is really how i
believe the new testament
reconciles hell with with the
idea of all being saved you see hell
is the purifying fire of god's
love but it is not forever god's love
will transform and heal us
all good and bad alike it's grace
all the way down for us i'll close
um with this the famous writer and roman
catholic christian
um flannery o'connor she wrote a
beautiful
brilliant brilliant short story um
titled revelation
and it begins in a doctor's office
where a very sort of pharisaical
religious person named miss turpin and
her husband
claude i like that claude are waiting
with others for their appointments and
the whole time
basically ms turpin just she just spends
the entire time
um sizing up comparing
herself and basically just
generally feeling superior to all the
different types of people there
um and there's people like of different
races and classes and body types and
various temperaments
like all these people she just observes
them and kind of inwardly she is just
she's a she's a judger he's very smug
and self-righteous
um but suddenly her moment
of a heavenly revelation comes
when a woman named grace
that judge wink week grace get it all
right
grace god okay grace throws a book at
her
right at her face and calls her so
strange calls her you old warthog that's
what she says
in this moment jars the fair cycle miss
turpin um
into the space a very kind of like quiet
self-reflection
and and internal crisis i mean you know
she's such a good person
she's not she's not an old warthog and
uh toward the end of the story
miss turpin sees a vision of
the day capital d day the day of
judgment flannery o'connor writes this
a visionary light settled in her eyes
she saw the streak as a vast swinging
bridge
extending upward from the earth
through a field of living
fire you see the image it's the fire
and upon it a vast horde of souls
were tumbling toward heaven
there were whole companies of white
trash clean for the first time in their
lives and
battalions of freaks and lunatics all
shouting and clapping and leaping like
frogs
and bringing up the end of the
procession
was a tribe of people whom she
recognized at once
as those who like herself and claude
had always had a little of everything
and the god-given wit to use it right
and she leaned forward to observe them
closer
they were marching behind
the others remember the new testament
the idea of the first shall be last the
last shall be first
right they were marching behind the
others with great dignity
accountable as they'd always been for
good order and common sense and
respectable behavior
they alone were on key yet she could see
by their shocked and altered faces
that even their virtues were being
burned away
that's it that's it
and you might you might say like well
but wait it's their virtues the virtues
they thought virtues were good things
well remember she's a prideful religious
person so even the things she thought
were so
good if they weren't rooted in the soil
of love even those things are being
burned
away you see hell is not a moment
in which we see the dark side of god
hell is not a place where the bad people
are sent forever and ever
no hell is the furious love
of god burning away everything that
would hold us back
from being united with him it's
beautiful
it's not comfortable it's not nice
but it's good and if miss turpin
and her kind of people can be saved
well i guess uh god really can't save
anyone
you pray with me lord jesus
we thank you that you
are infinite love and goodness and we
thank you that you are
absolutely committed in this life and in
the next
to purify and cleanse us of everything
that would hold us back from you so god
may we say yes to you
may we and in response to your love may
we live
lives of love
thank you for setting us free
in the powerful name of jesus i pray
amen
[Music]
is
and all of these
[Music]
me
we will cry
[Music]
oh
they'll know that you
[Music]
me
will see
[Music]
me
hello
[Music]
oh
is
[Music]
go on
is
[Music]
me
to mind
[Music]
oh
is is
wow guys i have so many notes
and um that doesn't even include
probably a quarter of the scriptures
that were named tonight
but i'm just so grateful
for a space to think and be challenged
and introduced
um to these different ideas and concepts
to wrestle with
and um and i'm just so grateful for the
grace with which it's being done
um man josh brock thank you for your
worship
it was truly so powerful
and so connecting and a gift i'm so
grateful
um brett tilford you're just the hottest
pastor i've ever known
he's never gonna ask me to do this role
again on services after that
but um i love a good nerd i love him
and um that was really really good
really so deeply meaningful
it's it just is like a fresh awakening
to the love of christ
and i just i'm so grateful um marissa
and scott backstage
thank you for tonight and thank you to
everyone who joined us
we do ask if this is
a place where you are finding life
and you are connecting if you agree with
the values and the vision of the table
you are invited to give to help this
community continue to
flourish and you can do that online at
thetabletx.org
and um any gift
matters and makes a difference so you're
invited to do that
um no pressure at all period
but um but always welcome and um
please remember that next week we
will not be here at this time we will be
at pleasant valley united methodist
church
in saxi live to do a one-year
celebration
with all of you we would love to see
your faces
we would love to pray over you we would
love to serve communion to you
we would love to give you a gift just to
say thank you to god
and thank you to you guys for being part
of this for the last year
so we are truly blessed i send you out
with a blessing
tonight that you could each go um
in the grace of god and in the power of
the holy spirit
and in the furious fiery purifying love
of christ
we love you all bye
you